المجنون من جديد
لا لا! ليس مجنون عفوا!،
تمهل! يا صديقي فالكثير من المتابعين
ينزعجون من هذا الاسم
بل الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ أون،
تبادل الهدايا مع زعيم روسيا قبل سنتين
وسلما على بعضهما أمام العالم
لكن ما الذي جرى خلف الكواليس يا ترى؟
توافق كبير للمصالح بين كيم وبوتين،
وكيم أرسل رسائل مباشرة لأمريكا عبر اليابان،،
بينما يستمر الشرق والغرب بإلقاء التهم
على موسكو باستهداف المدارس والمدنيين
يرد الكرملين ويؤكد أنه يقصف أهدافا
عسكرية بحتة وبصواريخ متطورة،،،
وموسكو تعلنها: حياد أوكرانيا يعني انتهاء
عملياتنا العسكرية، وبريطانيا تطلق التصريحات
وتهدد من بعيد
ولكن روسيا لا تعيرها اهتماما،
قوات أوكرانيا تتعرض لخسائر فادحة
في الأرواح والعتاد، فكم بإمكانها أن تصمد؟،،
أما الغرب فيحاول ثني الصين عن مساعدة
روسيا ولكن يبدو أن الوقت قد تأخر أيها الغربيون!
وكيف يمكن لأمريكا أن تساعد أوكرانيا
وهي لم تستطع الحفاظ على هذه المساعدات
من السرقة عندما كانت في أرضها؟
(تحالف الأقوياء)
وزارة خارجية كوريا الشمالية تقول
أن "السبب الجذري للأزمة الأوكرانية
يكمن في إرادة الولايات المتحدة وغطرستها،
التي ظلت متمسكة بالعقوبات والضغط
أحادي الجانب، وتسعى فقط إلى الهيمنة العالمية
والتفوق العسكري، متجاهلة مطالب
روسيا المشروعة باحترام أمنها".
علاقة بوتين وكيم جونغ تعود إلى الواجهة
مع تحالف اقتصادي عسكري يكسر الجمود
ويضع أمريكا في مأزق،
وكان الحزب الحاكم في كوريا الشمالية
قد أعلن التعبئة العامة لأجل حليفهم الروسي
الذي يتعرض لضغوطات غربية،
والاستعداد لأي شيء سيحدث..
بوتين ومجنون كوريا كيم جونغ،
في تحالف يرعب الغرب ويحسبون له ألف حساب،
(وهذه صور لتوثيق ذاك التحالف)
حتى أن تجارب الزعيم الكوري للأسلحة
باتجاه اليابان تجعل أمريكا
في موقف لا تحسد عليه..
(بريطانيا تحاول الظهور)
خرج رئيس الوزراء بوريس جونسون وقال،
الصمت عن أفعال بوتين ضوء أخضر لمهاجمة
جورجيا ودول البلطيق ...
وأضاف: من الضروري إنهاء الغرب اعتماده
على موارد الطاقة الروسية
جونسون تحدث أيضا لصحيفة التايمز:
بكين ستواجه عواقب إذا ساعدت روسيا
على التهرب من العقوبات الغربية،
ونحذر الصين من مغبة اختيار جانب الشر.
كما قال أنه لا يستبعد زيارته للرئيس
فولوديمير زيلينسكي في أوكرانيا.
(رد روسيا)
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجية الروسي
سيرغي لافروف: نأمل انتهاء العمليات العسكرية
باتفاق على حياد أوكرانيا،
حياد الدولة الأوكرانية والضمانات الأمنية
يجب صياغتها، في إطار حضاري قانوني ..
وأردف: إرسال قوات سلام من الناتو
إلى أوكرانيا فكرة غوغائية
وواشنطن تقبض على يد الوفد المفاوض
وتمنعه من أبسط شروطنا..
لافروف يقول أيضا:
التنسيق بين روسيا والصين في ظل الظروف
الحالية سيصبح أقوى
(الرد الصيني)
بعد موقف اتسم بالغموض حاول الغرب
استمالة التنين الصيني إلى صفهم لكن بكين.
هاجمت العقوبات الغربية على موسكو
ووصفتها بالفظيعة،
حيث قال نائب وزير الخارجية الصيني
لي وو تشانج : (عقوبات الغرب على روسيا
أصبحت مشينة أكثر فأكثر،
والعقوبات لا يمكن أن تحل المشاكل
بل تضر المواطنين وتؤثر على النظام
الاقتصادي المالي العالمي، )
كما أعلن عن عدم إدانة ما أسماه بالعمليات
العسكرية في أوكرانيا ولم يقل أنه غزو،
وأضاف: الناتو لا يجب أن يتوسع شرقا،
حتى لا يحشر روسيا في الزاوية.
(التطورات والأحداث)
وزارة الدفاع الروسية: مقتل أكثر من
100 من القوات الخاصة الأوكرانية والمرتزقة
بقصف قاعدة عسكرية في جيتومير.
المتحدث باسم انفصاليي دونيتسك:
مقتل 70 عسكريا أوكرانيا في المعارك
مع قواتنا خلال 24 ساعة.
مكتب رئيس الوزراء البولندي:
ارتفاع عدد اللاجئين الذين وصلوا منذ بداية
الحرب إلى أكثر من 2.8 مليون لاجئ.
رويترز عن وزير الخارجية التركي:ء
أوكرانيا وروسيا تقتربان من الاتفاق
بشأن القضايا المهمة.
الدفاع الروسية: سفن أسطول بحر قزوين
تقصف أهدافا عسكرية أوكرانية
بصواريخ مجنحة من طراز كوليبر.
نائبة رئيس الوزراء الأوكراني:
الاتفاق على فتح 7 ممرات أحدها من ماريوبول
لإجلاء المدنيين وتسليم مساعدات.
الكرملين: قواتنا استخدمت مجددا
صواريخ فرط صوتية من طراز كينجال
في قصف منشأة عسكرية أوكرانية.
الدفاع الروسية تعلن عن تدمير 69 نقطة
عسكرية أوكرانية بطائرات مسيرة..
مقاتلون شيشان يشتبكون مع قوات أوكرانية
في ماريوبول
الدفاع الأوكرانية تعلن تدمير ١٢ هدفا روسيا في أوكرانيا..
سرقة ٤٠٠ سترة واقية من الرصاص،
في نيويورك كانت في طريقها إلى أوكرانيا..
وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية: أسقطنا 3 مروحيات
للقوات الروسية  وأبدنا فرقة الإنزال المظلي
التي هاجمت كييف.
أعلنت أوكرانيا إيقاف حركة القطارات
مع جارتها بيلاروسيا
كشفت 3 مصادر مطلعة عن أن الولايات المتحدة
اقترحت على تركيا -على نحو غير رسمي-
إرسال أنظمة دفاع صاروخي روسية الصنع
من طراز إس-400 إلى أوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في محاربة القوات الروسية.
مع توقع أمريكي برفض الأتراك لهذا المقترح..
عمليات أمريكية فرنسية مشتركة
في البحر الأسود، بهدف تعزيز القدرات المشتركة.
حيث أجرت حاملة طائرات أمريكية عمليات
مشتركة مع حاملتي طائرات فرنسية وأخرى إيطالية
كيريل بتكوف رئيس الوزراء البلغاري:
حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا نبهتنا لما يمكن
لبوتين فعله، ولذلك قررت بلغاريا تعزيز نظامها الدفاعي.
باستخدام أقماره الصناعية في شركة
(سبايس إكس)، يقوم الملياردير الأمريكي
إيلون ماسك بمساعدة القوات الأوكرانية
بتحديد مواقع ودبابات القوات الروسية،
الرئيس الأوكراني يطالب سويسرا بتجميد
أموال الأثرياء الروس لأنهم بحد قوله
يساعدون بأموالهم في تدمير بلاده..
قال وزير الدفاع الأمريكي لويد أوستن،
أن أمريكا لا تعترض على تقديم الدول
الأخرى المساعدات العسكرية إلى أوكرانيا..
الرئيس الأوكراني يكرم مقاتلين
لاكتشافهم مجموعة استطلاع روسية
صاروخ كينجال الروسي المرعب
يدخل خط العمليات العسكرية في أوكرانيا،
وهو صاروخ بالستي يدمر السفن
ويحمل ذخائر نووية، ويصيب أهدافه بدقة
كما أن سرعته تصل إلى ١٠أضعاف سرعة الصوت..
زيلينسكي يحذر روسيا من تبعات العنف
وأن الرد سيكون قاسياً بالنسبة لهم
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تنشر صورا لأسلحة غريبة في أوكرانيا
مجنون كوريا مع دب روسيا النتيجة حتمية
بحلف لا يقهر، سيضاف لهذا الحلف تنين صيني عظيم،
يبدو أن هذا التحالف قد أبعد أوكرانيا عن الغرب
وأخافها وجعلها تتقدم خطوات نحو التفاوض،
فهل تقطع كييف علاقتها بالغرب وأمريكا
وتسقط في أحضان الروس،
خيار يبدو قاسيا للأوكران لكنه أقرب للواقع،
بانتظار أن يجد جديد في هذه القضية....